ils étaient douze à enfiler leurs
combinaisons à l'occasion de la deuxième
journée de formation à l'agriculture qui
a eu lieu à la bergerie nationale
alors on a à la fois du grand public
complètement
non initiés qui vient ici avant
d'acheter des ruches ou de se lancer
dans l'apiculture passer pour le stage
de découverte
et puis là aujourd'hui c'est un stage de
perfectionnement donc on a des gens qui
gèrent déjà quelques ruches
on peut avoir aussi des professionnels
l'environnement du paysage qui dans le
cas de leurs activités grdf la formation
a commencé avec les technique d'enfumage
des abeilles
le but pour la bergerie à prendre aux
participants à se perfectionner pour
développer ou pérenniser son boucher on
s'y intéresse mais tout le monde pense
aussi que c'est facile donc mais nous on
est aussi là pour aiguiller les gens les
aider à faire les bons choix se lancer
ou pas tout seul ou accompagné
amateurs ou professionnels les inscrits
à cette formation ont pu compléter leur
première journée découverte du 22 mai au
sein d'un des trois gauchers et des 70
colonies d'abeilles de la bergerie j'ai
en fait dans la maison familiale à des
ruches depuis très longtemps et la
personne qui s'en occupe
peut plus s'en occuper donc voilà le but
c'est de se former pour pouvoir prendre
la relève sur la gestion du riche et
donc un peu on va dire un cadre organisé
ce soit plus clair dans ma tête donc
puis là franchement c'est très bien
c'est super secteur la bergerie
nationale organise cette formation deux
fois par an au printemps pour respecter
le rythme des abeilles